[Applause]
first up i would say after 30 years in
the game the jury is in he is one of the
great american filmmakers of all time
his new novel is once upon a time in
hollywood based on his oscar-winning
film of the same name please welcome
quentin tarantino
hey you hey how you doing all right
[Applause]
[Music]
how you doing oh good man it's been too
long
so anyway this really brought me back to
my youth that was the idea
yeah well the whole movie did and we'll
get to that but it just look i remember
when these kind of came out yeah a
boovie yeah yeah
book after the movie well imagine me
going to a publisher and saying look uh
i know the money is in hardbacks but can
we come out with a paperback first
yeah well it's just
first of all i just got to say this
movie before we get to the book
i cannot where there are no words to
tell you how much this movie delighted
me tickled me and i i i i hadn't heard
that on the show yet uh so i didn't know
how you felt that's really great
i'm not a movie no i know i know fiscal
i don't say but i got the impression
even though you there was one time you
kicked django to the curb but then you
refer to it all the time
then next would be the next thing i see
parallels with the
with this one in django it's kind of a
buddy movie
dalton is a bounty hunter character no
man django they are bounty hunters yeah
uh-huh
you know and and django has to be an
actor yeah i mean there's a
i love i love chad i love all your there
is not one frame of your movies
that i have not seen multiple times but
i have to say
i'm getting to a point here thank you
thank you man no it's true
to me this is your your latest one is
your peak
this is my favorite of all time so what
is this nonsense
about you're only going to make one more
movie
uh well come on
yeah you know well okay i you i
look it's
uh you're too young to quit and you
you're
at the top of your game why that's why i
want to quit
how do you know it's the top
because i know film history and from
here on
end directors do not get better that's a
terrible idea
first of all you're judging yourself by
other people how do you [ __ ] know
you're 58 yeah yeah uh-huh 58's the new
57.
no no no okay i mean
plenty of people have come on i haven't
retired yet i still have another one to
go
what do why just one okay but the thing
about look look one
30 i don't have a look i don't
i don't have a reason that that i would
want to say out loud that
that's going to win any argument in a
court of public opinion or a supreme
court or anything like that
but it is just you know at the same time
working for
30 years doing as many movies as i've
done which like not as many as other
people but like that's that's a long
career
that's a really long career but why did
it happen and i've given and i've given
it
everything i have every single solitude
everything i have
you'll be bored you're going to want to
do it
really but i know first of all but i do
look but i look okay but it's a way this
is
this is okay this is just a random
example this is a random example but
then i
you know you look at a director like don
segal who actually had one of his best
uh decades in the centuries yeah exactly
with his collaboration with eastwood
oh my god if he had quit his career in
1979 when he did escape from alcatraz
what a final film how what what a mic
drop
yeah all right but he does like dribbles
away with two more other ones
they don't even know who he is yeah
but you know who he is i do but there's
other clint eastwood you mentioned
clinton
yeah that's one of the other ones if you
only bring up like two or three guys oh
i mean bran torino when he was 110 and
it's one of my favorites
he's still making movies okay yeah i'll
just i mean just say one more thing
about it okay
to me like we started around the same
time yeah you absolutely started okay
same time and of course i'm at the top
of my game yeah yeah yeah
uh so i freaking quit now the country's
helped you
i'm giving you [ __ ] to talk about okay
all right
anyway but you accumulate skills as you
go forward
you get better that's why i'm telling
you i think your last one was the best
one
would you have made if you were making
reservoir dogs
tomorrow would you make the exact same
movie no
you think you could make it even better
um you're not that's kind of a
captured time in a moment kind of thing
but i mean i i actually
considered about doing a remake of
reservoir dogs as my last movie i won't
do it internet
all right but i i considered it
you